bonsoir ça va entrez entrez entrez
dernière réunion publique avant le
premier tour face à des creusotins déjà
conquis david marty le maire sortant va
présenter son équipe et les grandes
lignes de son programme électoral
l'enjeu majeur pour cette élection
municipale c'est de présenter un
programme qui soient crédibles
réalisables et qui aille dans le sens de
ce que nous avons commencé ces dernières
années en termes d'attractivité
on a vu de solidarité d'accueil avec ce
souci de développement durable et de
préservation du climat le suivi un
programme qui se revendique à gauche
mais qui bénéficie du soutien de la
république en marche
un rapprochement qui ne passe pas pour
un allié historique du maire sortant
le pcf appelle à ne pas voter pour david
marty c'est la reine qui a décidé qu il
pouvait continuer de travailler comme
nous l'avions fait jusqu'à présent
durant ce mandat est ce que ça peut
nuire
peut-être je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas j'ai été jusqu'au bout de ma
conviction qui était de rassembler parce
que je suis maire sortant et que dans
une municipale
ce qui est important c'est de rassembler
ne pas diviser autre ancien allié de
david marty à prendre ses distances
pierre étienne graffard tête de liste
pour europe ecologie les verts au
creusot ils espèrent profiter des bons
scores des écologistes aux élections
européennes de 2019 ce que nous avons
cette ligne existe que ouvertement de
gauche écologique et solidaire avec tous
ceux qui partagent la préoccupation
environnementale et climatique et
écologique dans notre pays principal
leitmotiv pour les verts faire entrer
cette ville industrielle dans la
transition écologique l'industrie sur le
creusot
c'est un atout par contre il faut
trouver de nouvelles solutions pour
pallier aux faiblesses de cette mono
activité
on a une autre proposition forte aussi
sur notre projet qui est d'inscrire le
creusot non en territoire réservé aux
chômeurs afin d'offrir effectivement
plus grand nombre les emplois quelles
que soient leurs cales niveau de
qualification l'emploi c'est aussi la
priorité pour lutte ouvrière
ces luttes ouvrières on vous annonce
qu'on présente une liste au creusot très
la tête de liste
déjà présente lors des municipales de
2014 julie le code continue de défendre
la cause des travailleurs au creusot
l'enjeu majeur ici comme ailleurs c'est
d'avoir un travail de faire vivre sa
famille et de se soigner
vous comprenez aujourd'hui les
travailleurs ils sont attaqués tous les
jours que ça soit dans la santé que ça
soit chômage que ce soit précarité et
puis dernièrement les retraites
alors oui il va falloir faire entendre
le camp des travailleurs dans ces
élections avec trois listes
la gauche part divisée au creusot une
situation qui pourrait bien profiter à
charles landre membres des républicains
il présente une liste sans étiquette
pour rassembler davantage en 2014 il
avait recueilli 48 % des suffrages au
second tour
jamais vu ça moi j'ai mon numéro de
portable personnel ça fait un demi
siècle que la ville est dirigée par la
même équipe puisqu'il ya des élus qui
sont là depuis 1977
je crois qu'avec le temps et bien des
idées l'imagination et d'ambition sont
érodés et les réponses sont apportées ne
sont pas à la hauteur des enjeux
notamment en termes de développement
économique de création d'entreprise en
termes de sécurité aussi la ville est
confrontée à de graves difficultés
sociales comme au quartier du tennis
pour l'ensemble des candidats aux
municipales le retour à l'emploi est la
meilleure solution pour résoudre ces
problèmes
la priorité c'est le développement
économique le retour à une vraie
ambition économique en s'appuyant sur
les atouts de notre territoire nous
sommes qu'à 39 minutes de lyon à 1h20 de
paris on a ici tout pour réussir
malheureusement encore perdu 1000
habitants 50 et moi je croit dans le
potentiel cette ville et je crois
vraiment qu'on peut faire ici de belles
et grandes choses aux européennes le
rassemblement national est arrivé en
tête au creusot avec plus de 24% des
suffrages mais ne présente pas de listes
à ce scrutin
reste à savoir vers qui se porteront ses
électeurs